[موسيقى]
هذه اللوحات بريشه الملكه فريده في النصف
الثاني من حياتها انتهت الفن التشكيلي هذه
اللوحات تمثل حقبه من حياتها ربما لا يعرف
عنها الكثير من الاجيال الجديده
تعلمت الملكه فريده الرسم على يد خالها
الفنان التشكيلي محمود سعيد وبدات حياه
جديده كفنانه تشكيليه تنتمي اعمالها الى
ما يسمى بالفن الفطري للكبار
صديقي
يا باشا لانني كنت قريبا جدا جدا
الملك فاروق ثم قامت الثوره والرسم
بالنسبه لها كان سبيلا ان تبقى قريبه من
مصر والمصريين
[موسيقى]
المعرض ده يعني بيدي فكره للناس مش بس عن
الملكه فريده كملكه ولكن بيدي فكره عن
حياتها بعد ثوره 52 لان هي بعد 52 اشتغلت
في الرسم بقت ترسم عشان تقدر تكسب ال ال
ال المعيشه بتاعتها
فبيدي فكره للناس عن جنب ممكن يكون كثير
ما يعرفوهوش
[موسيقى]
مقتنيات المتنوعه للملكه فريده زوجه الملك
فاروق الاولى وبعد افراد اسره محمد علي
التي حكمت مصر منذ القرن 19 وحتى قيام
ثوره يوليو كل جزء هنا يحكي قصه عن تاريخ
مصر
[موسيقى]
بعض المجوهرات الخاصه بالملكه فريده
ومقتنيات اخرى لاسره محمد علي عرضت
بمناسبه مرور عامين على متحف المركبه
الملكيه ربما لا يعرف الناس الكثير عن هذه
الفتره من تاريخ مصر
احنا عايزين هناكل كذا اميره بس طبعا هي
شخصيه السنه دي هي شخصيه الملكه فريده
عاملين لها معرض للوحاتها الفنيه اللي هي
قسمتها بيديها عندنا بعض المجوهرات الخاصه
بها
الخديوي اسماعيل في افتتاح قناه السويس هي
صنيه من الذهب المجذع بالماس وعدد 24 لايك
في قهوه همم صينيه قطعه مميزه عن الخديوي
اسماعيل وما زالت بالحاله الجيده بتاعتها
طب انا شايفه هنا برده
جلسه العرش الخاصه بالملك فؤاد ودي كانت
موجوده في قصر الجوهره وكان في قاعه
موجوده كامله ليه
اهم حاجه في الموضوع اللي يسعدنا ان احنا
ابتدينا ناخذ بالنا ان ده جزء من تاريخنا
ومش مفروض ان احنا نتنازل عنه مش ان احنا
نعديه دي حلقه من حلقات التاريخ لكن يجب
ان تحترم يجب ان ان واتساب ويجب انها تفضل
موجوده ما ما تختفيش
الملكه فريده واسمها الحقيقي فريده ذو
الفقار تزوجت الملك فاروق لمده عشر سنوات
انجبت منه ثلاثه بنات وفي سنواتها الاخيره
عادت الملكه فريده لتعيش في مصر حتى
وفاتها المنيه في عام 88 لتترك هذه
الاعمال ذكرى لا تنتهي وجزءاما من تاريخ
مصر سمر باشات لصباح العربيه من القاهره
[موسيقى]